I see Sarah Paulsen is my sister
Cuba Gooding jr. sets the record
straight on these photos with Sarah
Paulsen that caused a bit of controversy
I noticed all of this there was some
Twitter's noise about a picture of her
and I but this is there's no disrespect
that she's I love her like I do my
daughter and other women powerful women
in my life
kuba and Sarah both attended the FX
upfront red carpet event in New York
City Thursday the actors will join
forces yet again on the upcoming season
of Katrina American crime story
well if AJ was 200-foot yacht katrina is
going to be a cruise letter i hope they
take away again another very emotional
experience that shocks the core of this
nation google confirmed he's been
approached to star in showrunner Ryan
Murphy's other projects as well but
stayed coy about which one
as for rumors Paulson may play Princess
Diana in the upcoming season of feud
Charles and Diana kuba is on board she's
the top of the game for actresses in
this country
[Music]